father's day weekend and a lot of people
going all out for dad this year
according to the national retail
federation spending expected to top more
than 20
billion dollars this year that is a
record high the average person will
spend about 175 dollars
here's a list of the top gifts they
include cards
clothes a special outing like dinner or
brunch followed by
gift cards and of course a phone call is
as always
completely free yes all right
fifty 55 and we're looking ahead to
father's day here at good day las vegas
oh that's my dad steve
he's the best me and my father also
named john when i was a youngin over at
the beach
my sister allison there happy father's
day
happy father's day dad he's been having
some health issues back east and uh
hopefully he's doing well i'll talk with
him later today and this weekend as well
oh there's bianca and her dad what a
handsome man
yeah there you go
oh that looks like justin our executive
producer with
two of his beautiful daughters there
look at those pictures you guys
i like that i like that wow that's a
trip back yeah oh
here's chrissy this is our 6am producer
chrissy those are cute pictures yeah
happy father's day to your uh to your
father chrissy good stuff
and i think that was annie our 4am
producer
uh who is this this must be andrus oh
crystal oh crystal okay happy father's
day
everyone nate happy father's day to you
as well sir thank you so much
happy father's day yes